i want the lg and b to be separate from
everything else they know in 20 years if
this continues it's going to be
normalized yeah and who knows what comes
after this and after you know the trans
agenda the pedophile agenda whatever
[Music]
and
[Music]
latino american
he's very gay and he's to the right of a
till the hun and he's so scared he's
like man i've lost friends just because
we're going to vote for biden he's like
these people are the most unacceptable
in the world i've had
i've had uh
two people walk out on me on dates
because i said
trump's not that bad that's all i said
that's all you said remember walk off
okay you're gonna pay your bartenders
yeah
i got it
these ladies and these guys dudes okay
that's what i figured i got to tell you
it's always
no you know it's it's changing it's
changing it really isn't a huge gay
following of people just because they're
like look
they come to the shows they don't get
effect they know there's no hate like
again this you should list i wish this
guy would be on the show he's yeah i
tell this joke it's so funny he's he's
like flamboyantly gay very very latino
and uh he broke up with his boyfriend 18
years
older biden recruits and he was like
cause he betrayed me
i told him he's like i told him that if
you vote for biden and so what happened
is he he wasn't he's in an l.a but nice
in florida
and david i always joke about this and
he's like don't tell it on air but one
of his neighbors in la uh
has another neighbor who's like a syrian
migrant refugee
and had goats in the yard and he said
his neighbor who's a liberal sent him
like a news clipping and like goats and
he's like can you believe this he goes
can i believe it you voted for this i
hope he sets up a whole [ __ ] petting
zoo
i was sitting there like i'm trying to
breathe he's like [ __ ] you i hope you i
i like i hope this whole neighbor gets
calmed and went calmly when he tries to
[ __ ] it so i cannot care this guy is so
catty i'm like dude you gotta calm down
but he's he's just he's done with it
there's such a divide happening right
now and
and i agree with it i wanted i want the
lg and b to be separate from everything
else
the tea is a real problem for you guys
now when they're going after kids
you know they need hormone replacement
i've never wanted that
i remember the problem
right you don't even have to call it
marriage you can call it whatever you
want so i want to be able to be seen the
same right way in the eyes of the law
right as you know my straight
counterparts right but yeah it was the t
that sort of brought everything else
well man it's like people often because
sometimes when people say like oh
homophobic or transphobic oh look
the idea that we're gonna we're using
the chemical castration drugs it's the
same drug as these for kids the idea
that we're using this and saying the
science is out just talk about this
reversible it's irreversible the science
is not out on cancer science is not out
on endometriosis on infertility like we
know if you're a woman and you get
breast cancer i have a nanny who just
had a double mastectomy the first thing
i do is put you on an estrogen blocker
because if that gets high even for women
it's bad but for women
we know that it causes cancer the male
body is not meant to have that level of
estrogen it's just it's it's incredibly
corrosive oh i didn't know that oh yeah
yeah yeah it's a real problem and what's
funny is too where if you give you know
if men have higher testosterone it
actually helps with like metabolic
disorders like type 2 diabetes but if
women get testosterone it makes it worse
and so it's just your body is meant to
have a certain profile of hormones we
all know that because people right they
want to why are people eating organic
why are they drinking from glass bottles
opposed to plastic because they talk
about these you know hormones in the
food they talk about the xenoestrogens
you know the bpa plastic that's all it
is
when you inject it directly into a
nine-year-old's ass we don't know the
science it's really really scary and you
look at these kids who are trying to
transition back
and we're not going to see those effects
for another what ten years and how who
knows how many of our this younger
generation is going to be
you know already uh you know have that
stuff in their bodies how many of them
are just gay
and how many of them just may be gay and
then someone says you're trans i was i
was watching a podcast with this uh
she's a lesbian
and she
i bet she's fun at parties the same
thing the whole time well she's the same
ideas as us now being just gay is being
transphobic yes and
i don't like that either no i know what
i like this well and i think a lot of
too like with my um
gosh
i mean the truth is the gay thing is
like it's still in a binary you know i
mean it's still a binary or maybe
bisexual
but it's like we still acknowledge that
there are men and women the idea that
it's not a real thing that's that's a
totally different uh i mean it's a chasm
between someone being gay and someone
and by the way it's a chasm between like
i wrote this article this is a long time
ago in 2009
i wrote an article it was titled uh this
is when before breitbart became
breitbart it was just big hollywood and
i wrote an article titled elton john and
rush limbaugh agree on gay marriage and
well and john he said he said like why
do you need to push for like the
institution he said like civil union is
what you should push for so that way
everyone's happy and that's what rush
live said and by the way alan john
performed at rush limbaugh's
wedding yeah and uh
that's and then of course elton john got
just he just got escorted he had to walk
it back i'm like look even if you look
back there when people said everything
is homophobic it's really if you look in
california like full civil union full
rights we just want to separate the
marriage thing because of the church and
now you see what happens in canada but
in canada if you're a pastor and you
refuse to marry two men
you're done
that's the thing that's the problem like
they should be that's why the marriage
should be totally separate from the
church and the state anyway like i don't
even think i think the christian church
is screwed that up too it's like the
bible doesn't say and thou shalt have a
joint bank account you know i'm not even
after that i don't need to be married in
church i just want to be able to like
file taxes together right and like you
know not able to see my exact one in the
hospital in hospital or a well you know
yeah
exactly good that's all i want
twerking it in front of toddlers is uh
dude a thing though i know it's so
disgusting it's so [ __ ] here's the
thing it's disgusting people go like uh
it embarrasses me honestly
you know when people say it's a double
standard
i go where do you ever see it a straight
what
exactly it should be a drag show just
like you shouldn't be
yeah that's not the same thing
yeah we really distill it down it's our
culture and by the way it's not even
it's not even like this bar it's
severe a serious adult bar culture on
the streets
and that's the problem what are you
homophobic it's like i just don't want
to see next to my next to my wing dinner
you know it's all about normalization
that's what they're trying to do and
you know they know in 20 years if this
continues it's going to be normalized
yeah and who knows what comes after this
and after you know the trans agenda the
pedophile agenda whatever is going to
come i remember if if i say it as a
straight heterosexual male if i'm like a
pet they go are you comparing gays to
pedophilia like
no i'm not i'm saying that drag queen
story hour at a public library
is pedophilia at that point it's
sexualization of children that's not
because some of you i honestly think
places i'm like i could play spot the
game in and i don't even know they'll be
able to pick them out i'm like that's
just a dude dressed up like a woman who
still likes women i'm like so you're not
just yes yes so you have nothing to do
with gay people but you are stripping in
front of kids
no sure absolutely yeah yeah we're on
our way i was saying no everyone else
because we get security issues but i'm
on the way out you can do it everywhere
i appreciate it you know what's funny
we've been asking people today i've been
asking them is uh are you proud to be
american are you guys proud to be
american
you're proud to be an american yes sir
well at least i know i'm free greatest
country in the world
only people who aren't whites
are blacks asians mexicans are like yeah
man it's the greatest country and then
white women are like
i am the product of uh in an immigrant
family
i guess it's the hair right at six two
all right count three one two
dude thank you so much no thank you and
i appreciate man i know the balls it
takes to stand up and you're like i i
feel genuinely bad anymore i don't i i i
i bartend that's a liberal like you know
liberals all over the place right and
after the roe v wade everyone was
buzzing about it and i'm just like shut
up it doesn't belong in a bar with
alcohol i know however i'm not gloating
i don't care but also
i think it's the end of the world it's
like did you realize this is a very this
is something to me the roby weight thing
it's like this is a very very rare
instance okay for people who talk about
the supreme court right people talked
about
gay marriage all these issues and now
there's a problem there's overreach of
government this is a very rare instance
where the court
actually stepped back from power yeah he
said we're going to do nothing with this
and states can do whatever they want
like anyone who just says i believe in
freedom of power exactly
destroying democracy
by the unelected court saying this
should go to your elected officials like
i can't think of anything that is more
pro-democratic process than that
and but people think it's a ban on
abortion the people that are freaking
out the most
haven't even really read it no no they
don't understand it they don't get it i
know and so i don't know i know i did
about school like when i was growing up
they taught us the constitution they
taught us our rights they they did all
that now they're teaching something
completely different and uh it's ruining
it i'll tell you what it is
it's white
i really it's white women it's white
women i have a joke in center like we
don't need to build a wall in the
southern border we need one around every
single pottery barn just seal them in
until 2025 because they all become
teachers sorry true heroes
and uh
they have never worked in the private
sector most of our public school
teachers yes and we've even said this
today look you know this
it's a gay man probably better than i do
if you see a woman she's attractive and
she's with a man she's happy she's
conservative
if you see a woman who's past the point
of her window
and she's single she's miserable or
she's unattractive
she's always liberal she's always
there's
right now think about it biden is losing
with under 25 he's losing under 30. he's
lost he's losing blacks he's losing
latinos huge absolutely the only place
he still wins is suburban white women
and that's the same thing today black
like man i'm proud to be american i go
yeah what is it like man it ain't
perfect but i'm free and then white
you're like oh no i don't think so i'm
like really because the black guy you
claim to speak for that's marginalized
he says you're wrong yeah yeah and uh i
really think it's a disconnect and it's
people think it's an urban thing it has
become a suburban
predominantly it's generally women but
particularly white women latino women
aren't nearly liberal it's the white
women that are shutting those uh those
black voices down that are uh not saying
what they want
well
shutting down gay voices
jk rowling like turf
really really almost every gay guy
spoken with is like yeah the trans thing
is a problem like we're getting a little
this is going to be a problem for us
because we don't want to be lumped in
with that it's like white women are like
no turf it's lgbt i've never heard one
gay man
say
lgbtqaaip on ironically not one
in the in the media sure but in real
life i mean i'm sure you fought running
more
but i mean i feel like it gets some
areas here they're nice they're you know
it's not like it's not like uh san
francisco where they're always around
like chokers and stuff on the street
i mean you haven't been to pride
yeah
is it here since
yeah and what embarrasses me like i've
never been a private my first pride i
was invited to i moved here 15 years ago
and it was going to be my first ride and
i was invited to represent this bar that
i frequented and i was excited came in
that saturday
saw
the platform that i was going to be on
literally a flat bed like platform with
poles sticking out of it right that was
one thing and i went inside
they were the owner was like here wear
this
and i was like
okay and then i saw the baskets of candy
everywhere i was like oh stuffed animals
i was like what's this for it's like oh
it's for the kids
hold on you want me to wear this
and stand on this holding this pole
no absolutely not walked away
never been to a gay pride parade ever
after that oh my god because like i
don't there's nothing there that
represents me right and maybe if there
was like a group of like conservative
gay men that would oh they're absolutely
there there are tons now like i even
talk about this where it's like remember
the florida don't say gay bill just you
can't teach kids about sexual issues
but you haven't read it or not no no no
most people know i understand
well what's funny to me is there was
like you know lesbian on tick tock i
repeat myself right she she was like
this is the example of a double standard
of heterosexual of heterodoxy versus
lesbian women like yeah cause i'll we
all remember walking up to our second
grade teacher being like yeah by the way
who are you plowing like it never came
up
straight people didn't do it because i
didn't know their first name of my
teacher they're acting like straight
people are telling like this is my
partner this is what we do this is the
parade we attend it never came up
this is the group that wants to bring it
up with kindergarteners and it's like
then they
they say it's a double standard no
you're right it's a double standard
because of what you want to do these
little kids don't know any of these
things and they're already treating each
other equally yeah as a general rule
they tend to and then we screw them up
now we're putting this stuff in their
heads and it's like
well you give me hope for the country
man people like you and honestly i tell
you just talking to everyone here you'd
be amazed it's like i've been working on
this for a long time black americans are
inherently like
more conservative than any group they
just don't they just don't realize it
they vote for crap america
right yeah and most of them don't share
it so all right go i don't want to keep
you every haircut but thank you man
hey if you like this video hit that
notification bell up there uh or
subscribe or share this right isn't that
right dave smash that like button and
share it where would you wear it what
are you wearing there that's nice oh
this is uh i found it in the trash yeah
also known as
your shirt crowdershop.com which is
where you can go and support and uh
we
we have overs we keep the overstock in
the trash
except for people who are little yeah he
says i haven't earned it yet because i
hadn't grown all the way by the way if
you find hunter biden's gun in there
just let it be